foreign
[Music]
thank you I want to thank the organizers
for inviting me to share my work with
you my name is Rula Tamimi I'm a cancer
epidemiologist I'm a professor of
population Health Sciences at Wild
Cornell medicine and I'll be talking
today about the integration of molecular
and radiologic features as a way to
really understand breast cancer risk and
we'll discuss some of the implications
for risk assessment and prevention
I have no Financial disclosures
so in terms of learning objectives I
have three learning objectives for today
the first is to understand the
importance of thinking about the life
course and considering timing of
exposures I think this is important for
all cancers but especially for breast
cancer I'm going to talk a little bit
about mammographic density and our goal
is to really understand how mammographic
density is a risk factor for breast
cancer and then finally really to
understand how integrative epidemiology
can help us to understand how risk
factors influence disease and
specifically today Cancer
so the overview of my talk I'm gonna my
entire talk is about breast cancer so
I'm going to start with some descriptive
epidemiology I'm going to also give a
little bit of background on the nurses
health studies these are the the
epidemiologic study um that'll be the
foundation really for two of the uh
recent works that I'll highlight
um and then I'll I'll launch into three
areas of work the first looking at early
life body size is a risk factor for
breast cancer the second looking at
mammographic density is a risk factor
for breast cancer and then in the third
one um this will be in a different
population-based study but looking at
the impact of vitamin D supplementation
on breast tissue and then I'll close
with some final conclusions in future
directions
so in terms of descriptive epidemiology
as many of you know breast cancer is the
number one cause of cancer in women in
the United States and globally and there
are over 280 000 new cases of invasive
breast cancer diagnosed in the U.S each
year it's also the second most common
cause of cancer death in the United
States this is second only to lung
cancer with over 43 000 breast cancer
deaths each year in the United States
I like to show this graph this is a
graph that shows incidence rates and
mortality rates in different countries
those of high incidence and those of low
incidents and if we look at the brighter
pink bar I think what you can see is
that there's about a five-fold variation
in terms of incidence rates between High
incidence countries and low incidence
countries and some of this may be due to
detection
screening that's able to detect more
cancers there's also really the belief
that there are different risk factors
and the uptake of different risk factors
across these different different
populations that influence incidence
rates and so this gives us some idea
that there may be modifiable risk
factors or things that we can learn to
really think about how can we change
some of our behaviors or exposures in
order to reduce the risk of breast
cancer
in this graph we are looking at the
incidence rates of breast cancer in the
United States over time and we'll just
focus on this bright pink uh bar or the
bright pink the Top Line there and you
know I think it's important to look at
the trends over time to really see what
is the burden of disease in our
population and you can see that in the
1980s there was a wide increase or
there's a large increase in the
incidence rates of breast cancer and
this is really due to the uptake of
mammographic screening so with increased
screening we detected more cancers we
also see a continuing trend of increase
in breast cancer even between 1980s and
2000 and these are really thought to be
attributable to risk factors that have
been changing in the population so in
general women have been delaying
childbirth women have been having fewer
children there have been more hormonal
exposures both with oral contraceptives
and post-menopausal hormone use all of
these are risk factors and are really
acting in way to increase the risk of
breast cancer in our population
in addition to that we've experienced
the Obesity epidemic and we know that
post-menopausal obesity is a risk factor
for breast cancer
um there was a decline around 2001 and
this is really attributable to um there
was a publication that was uh published
in 2001 from a randomized control trial
showing that women who were on
um hormone hormone therapy and estrogen
plus progesterone hormone therapy were
an increased risk of breast cancer and a
number of women had been taking
um these drugs really a lot of them for
the thought that it could reduce
cardiovascular disease risk and a number
of women discontinued use and you can
see that turned into a demonstrable
um decline in incidence rates but really
since the 2000s or early 2000s incidence
rates have either plateaued or continue
to increase slightly and so this really
speaks to the fact that we are not doing
a good job in terms of preventing breast
cancer and so that's really the
motivation for a lot of my work is to
better understand risk factors and think
about how we can prevent future breast
cancers
and just in contrast these are the rates
of cardiovascular disease in the United
States and you can see since the 1950s
rapid declines in incidence rates of
cardiovascular disease so just taking a
very big picture view
um you know trying to contrast breast
cancer to cardiovascular disease why is
it the cardiovascular disease has seen
this great success in reducing the risk
of cardiovascular disease you know I
think there are some steps that we as
scientists as epidemiologists need to
undertake to really think through how we
can reduce incidence rates of breast
cancer and the first really comes down
to research and understanding the
science understanding the mechanisms by
which risk factors can influence disease
and then using that information can we
identify that those populations that are
really at the highest risk and Target
them either for actionable modifiable
risk factors such as you know for
cardiovascular disease it was stop
smoking exercise either pharmacology
magical interventions that do not
introduce toxicity and for breast cancer
you know I think we're still at the at
that first box I think we do understand
a lot of the science but identifying
those at highest risk were still in the
early phases I think we are getting
there and I'm going to show you some of
our work but I don't think we are nearly
as far as along as the cardiovascular
disease community
so now I'm going to shift a little and
take a little time to describe the
nurse's health studies these are a
series of studies these are large scale
they're all ongoing population studies
in which we enrolled large groups of
women who uh at least in nurses one uh
were nurses registered nurses in the
United States nurses one started in 1976
000 registered nurses agreed to
participate in this study they continued
to be followed up today every two years
we follow up with a questionnaire we ask
them about their lifestyle factors we
asked them about risk factors we asked
them if they've been diagnosed with any
diseases
um and we over time as you can see in
this picture have collected different
biospecimens toenails blood samples
urine saliva which has really allowed us
to really examine a number of different
disease exposure and disease
relationships and all of my talk today
will be really focused focused on breast
cancer nurses too is a very similar
study it was started in 1989 recognizing
that early life influences are really
important for breast cancer the
enrollment at Baseline we made an
earlier window so we started really
enrolling women as early as the age of
25 to 42. most recently there's a nurses
three this is an ongoing study that's
still open to enrollment if there is
anyone who's interested in enrolling
again recognizing how important early
life is we again sort of open the window
to enrollees all the way down to the age
of 19 and also enrolled male nurses as
well
thank you
so just taking a little bit closer look
into some of the study design issues
with respect to some of the work that
I'll be showing here I'm focusing on
nurses health study 2. again this study
started in 1989 with over 116 000 nurses
enrolled between the ages of 25 and 42
at Baseline
one of the things that we did was that
we collected blood samples from about a
third of the entire cohort was willing
to provide a blood sample we collected
blood from from this large subco of
women and then we continue to follow
these women to see Who develops this
disease and this allows us to examine
their blood sample prior to any disease
to really see does do these certain
molecular markers uh put individuals at
a higher or lower risk of cancer one of
the areas that I'll be talking about and
that I'm very interested in is using
mammographic images to be able to
predict later risk of breast cancer and
so we targeted our mammogram collection
to the same time that women provided a
blood sample so that we could also do
correlative work to see if there were
factors in the blood that predicted
either breast density or other Imaging
factors
we also collected tumor blocks so many
uh when people are diagnosed with tumors
many of their samples will be archived
in paraffin and we were able to go back
to pathology departments and retrieve
those pathology samples and use that
information to look at molecular
characteristics of their tumors
and then we also were able to do a
second blood collection
um in nurses to 10 years after the first
blood collection
and really what this allows us to do is
to do some integrative epidemiology so
to be able to look at how the DNA may
impact the mammographic features or how
their plasma metabolomics may increase
their risk of developing cancer and for
each of these we have subsets of
participants that may provide their DNA
or may provide Imaging
um and on all the women we do have
information on their lifestyle data we
also know where people live and we're
able to use geographic information
systems to also collect environmental
data
I'll just quickly highlight the guts
cohort which I did not mention before
but the guts cohort are the children of
nurses too
um and so when they were initially
enrolled they were between the ages of 9
and 17 whether they were in guts one or
guts two we continue to follow them up
today and this really allows us to
really look at again these early life
influences and how that may impact later
risk of disease and you can see here
that these individuals as of today are
still under mostly under the age of 40.
um so we're unable to look at breast
cancer as an outcome but I'm going to
talk about some intermediate outcomes
that may help us to understand breast
cancer etiology
so now I'm going to shift to my my first
research finding I'm going to talk about
early life body size and breast cancer
so I think it's important to recognize
that even though we think of breast
cancer as a disease of adults
um there are a lot of risk factors that
we know of that are established that are
happening much earlier in life even as
early as birth and in utero so we know
that birth size is positively associated
with breast cancer we also know that
markers of puberty such as menarchy is
associated with breast cancer we also
know exposures in their timing are
important so we know that radiation
especially during adolescence or early
life is a risk factor for breast cancer
and it's much stronger if that exposure
is early in life as opposed to later in
life with respect to its impact on
breast cancer risk and you can see
throughout the life course there are
different risk factors that are
associated with breast cancer
and I think especially when we think
about breasts there are different
periods in life where the breast
actually may be more vulnerable to
specific exposure so the breast is
undergoing
um mammary gland changes all the way
from gestation through puberty uh when
women go through pregnancy and lactation
these are all uh potential Windows of
physiologic change in which exposures
may act differently in the breast than
other periods of time and you know I
like this figure here which kind of
shows on the one hand
um the boxes you can see are sort of the
the life course stages and then the
white line above kind of goes through
the the the course of cancer how we go
from normal to hyperplasia dysplasia
eventually invasive cancer and so you
can see it's challenging to study Early
Childhood factors as that may relate to
invasive cancer but one thing that we've
tried to do is try and narrow that
Distance by looking at intermediate
markers of risk such as hyperplace Asia
or even understanding
um
molecular expression in the normal
breast to try and really understand how
some of these factors May influence
etiology of breast cancer
so one way that we uh study early life
body size and epidemiologic studies is
to use figures so these are pictograms
from one to nine and we ask individuals
to recall their own body shape body size
at different times during their life and
even though this seems sort of crude and
actually there's actually a fairly good
correlation
um when we had people recall it and when
we actually had measured BMI certainly
not perfect but it actually does a
relatively good job and in the nurse's
health study we asked individuals to
recall their
um this nine level pictogram at
childhood during adolescence and also at
age 20.
and what we found was a strong inverse
relationship so women who reported that
they were heavier or larger in size when
they were in adolescence had a reduced
risk of developing breast cancer later
in life and we also looked at different
molecular subtypes of breast cancer and
what was interesting is that we saw
equally strong associations for those
subtypes that our hormone receptor
positive and those subtypes that are
hormone receptor negative and just to
point out that this is actually a fairly
strong risk factor when we think about
sort of where this fits in or protective
Factor depending on how you want to
think about it but the association in
terms of its magnitude is quite strong
relative to some of our other
established risk factors
and I just want to share
um these you know we are not the only
city that has seen this this is um
generally been seen in many other
studies all over the world and in
different racial um and ethnic groups in
a fairly similar magnitude of
Association you can see these are just
four other studies that have been
published they may have looked at BMI at
different ages whether it was 14 or 20.
but you can see in general this sort of
strong inverse relationship that girls
that were heavier during this early life
period had a reduced risk of developing
breast cancer
one other thing that we tried to do
again in most of those studies it's
either recalled or actually in some of
those studies they were able to get
records from
um childhood records we were able to
prospectively look in that guts cohort
so the children of nurses too we were
able to look to see if their BMI that
was recorded when they were 10 was
associated with I mentioned this early
life risk or I'm sorry early earlier
intermediate markers of risk we looked
up benign breast disease so this is a
early uh marker of later risk of breast
cancer and we did see that among girls
who were heavy when they were age 10 had
a reduced risk of developing this benign
breast disease later in life again kind
of confirming in a prospective way that
early life
body size was associated with a reduced
risk of this early lesion
we also looked at mammographic density
we were able which is a risk factor for
breast cancer and I'm going to spend the
next part telling you a little bit more
about mammographic density but if you
can believe me right now that
mammographic density is a risk factor
for breast cancer you can see here that
we see a very similar Trend what we see
on the left panel is looking at the
relationship between these pictograms
and mammographic density and on the
right panel is the pictograms and risk
of breast cancer and again you can see
they parallel each other
um very similarly
and obviously you know we can't make
Public Health recommendations that
individuals should be heavy early in
life and so really our goal is to try
and better understand what is the
mechanism that having a larger body size
early in life may be important and can
we somehow translate that into a
preventative measure
one of the other things that we did was
um as you recall I I we collected tissue
samples from women who did develop
breast cancer and we were able to look
at the gene expression profiling in
their tumor tissues and what we found
was that there were different molecular
profiles for cases if dependent on their
adolescent body size so we found that if
we looked at both ER positive and er
negative breast cancers larger
adolescent body size was inversely
associated with proliferative Pathways
we also saw this especially for the ER
negatives which I think is especially
important because ER negative breast
cancer is a more aggressive subtype of
breast cancer and we've identified fewer
risk factors so we know that um this
body size early life body size is
inversely associated with ER negative
breast cancer and seems to be operating
through reducing proliferative Pathways
as well as well as immune response and
inflammation
the final piece of evidence
um that we have you know really
supporting this inverse Association
comes from jiwa studies so these are
genome-wide Association studies and we
in which we look at genetic markers and
genetic scores for different exposures
and look at what that Association is
with breast cancer and this was work
done by qigao showing that a genetic
score for childhood BMI was inversely
associated with post-menopausal breast
cancer risk
so I think together this
provides robust evidence that early life
adiposity is inversely related to breast
cancer risk we see the strong evidence
with these intermediate markers we took
this multidisciplinary approach with
complementary data of course again the
the real goal of this is is not that we
would come up with public health
recommendations to change people's BMI
early in life but really to think about
are there ways that we can harness this
information
and use that to develop prevention
strategies I think this also
demonstrates how important that we
consider the life course when we're
thinking about risk accumulation Windows
of suspect susceptibility
especially when we're thinking about
breast cancer
I'm now going to switch to mammographic
density
so mammographic density
um we often refer to percent
mammographic density which refers to the
percent on a mammogram the percent of
the image that is occupied by dense
tissue so on a mammogram if you look at
the um one closest to the left which
says None
um there's very little white tissue the
white tissue is the dense tissue and the
and the dark on the image is fat and so
um you can see that this this represents
increasing categories of percent breast
density on a mammographic image and the
bars below it represent the risk
associated with that so someone all the
way to the right who has more than 75
percent of their breast area on that
mammographic image occupied by dense
tissue has about a five-fold risk of
developing breast cancer compared to the
woman all the way on the left who has a
primarily fatty breast
so just a few things about mammographic
density it is a extremely strong
predictor of breast cancer risk many of
the breast cancer risk factors that are
established are also associated with
breast density in a similar Direction
breast density also tends to track well
over time so women tend if they are high
pre-menopausally even though your breast
density may change over time if they're
high premenopausaly they tend to be high
postmenopausaly there is some evidence
that you can change your breast density
and that those changes
um are associated with risk so we have
in many studies used mammographic
density as an intermediate marker of
breast cancer risk
one of the first studies that I did with
respect to mammographic density was
looking at circulating estradiol there
had been this hypothesis in the
literature that mammographic density
must represent a woman's exposure to
estrogens and that's why it's such a
strong risk factor and and why we might
think of it as an intermediate marker of
risk we were able to in the nurse's
health study because we collected
mammograms at the same time that we
collected blood samples we were able to
see is there an association between
circulating estradiol levels and
mammographic density
we did not find a cross-sectional
association between circulating
estradiol and mammographic density
um this analysis that I'm showing on
this graph here if you look at the left
hand panel is looking at estradiol
levels and what you can see is that
within if you look at the red boxes you
can see that the increasing estradiol
levels are associated with increasing
risk of breast cancer so in that fourth
quartile women with high estrodial
levels have about a two and a half fold
increased risk of developing breast
cancer compared to women in that lowest
quartile when we account for
mammographic density it really makes no
difference suggesting that their
independent associations
we did the converse on the on the right
so here on the right graph we're looking
at quartiles of mammographic density
this just also shows you what a strong
risk factor mammographic density is if
you look at women in the highest
quartile in that red box they have an
almost four-fold risk of developing
breast cancer compared to women in the
lowest
um and when we adjusted for estradiol it
really makes no difference again
suggesting that their independent risk
factors for breast cancer I will note
that this these these analyzes were done
in post-menopausal women so
um it certainly does not preclude that
perhaps earlier in life women's uh early
life estradiol levels may be associated
with a mammographic density
another analysis that we did was to look
at percent mammographic density and
later risk of breast cancer and to see
was it associated with ear positive or
ER negative uh subtypes of breast cancer
and we found that mammographic density
was strongly associated with both ER
positive and er negative tumors
um in our in this particular analysis we
are showing that it's actually stronger
for ER negative breast tumors but I
think that what's important is that it's
a strong risk factor for both and I
think this also speaks to the fact that
it is likely independent of estrogen
mediated pathways
in this next analysis what we did was we
cross-classified people really tried to
ask the question what if a woman had
high estradiol levels and high
mammographic density and what we found
is that if she had both of these things
especially if you focus on the women
that never used exogenous hormones those
women were at a particularly high risk
of breast cancer compared to women who
had low estradiol and low mammographic
density
we did a similar analysis here
um looking at polygenic risk scores so
these are genetic polymorphisms that
have been demonstrated in genome-wide
association studies to be associated
with breast cancer risk and are also
very strong predictors of breast cancer
and again you can see we did quintiles
of polygenic risk score and quartiles of
percent breast density here and you can
see there's a really you know spreading
out of risk so that women who have high
genetic risk and high mammographic
density are at a much higher risk
compared to women who may be low on both
of those factors
and I think this is really important
because both of these factors the
polygenic risk score and mammographic
density have been helping us to improve
our risk prediction models this is work
that we did in the nurses health study
and some of you may be familiar with the
Gale model and there are several risk
prediction models I think the Gale model
and the tire kuzik model are two models
that are used uh more more regularly
within the clinics but they really don't
do they do a good job of predicting how
many breast cancers there might be in a
population they don't really do a great
job of discriminating you know which of
two women is really the woman that's
most likely to get breast cancer and we
use this AUC metric to kind of get at
that discrimination and if the AUC was
50 it means it's as good as flipping a
coin and so you know the original Gale
model in our population was 55 so really
not that great but you can see with the
addition of polygenic risk score the
addition of mammographic density the
addition of circulating hormone levels
all of these things together are
actually helping to move this away from
sort of the 50 and actually to a point
where it would be performing well in the
clinics to identify those women at the
highest risk
so to conclude the mammographic density
section mammograph intensity is a strong
predictor of breast cancer mammographic
density and I didn't get time to talk
about it today but other Imaging
features that we've identified are
associated with both ER positive and er
negative disease
um some of our other work is really
addressing some of these novel Imaging
features and they really do predict
um increase our ability to predict
breast cancer risk
um and and so you know I think the we
will be moving to risk prediction models
that include more than just traditional
questionnaire based factors that will be
incorporating biomarkers and imaging I
think really is the is the future
and the final research vignette I would
like to share with you is the impact of
vitamin D supplementation on breast
tissue
so there are several lines of evidence
that suggest that vitamin D may play a
role in breast carcinogenesis we know
this from cell line models and animal
models and it seems to be associated
with both reducing risk of ear positive
and er negative breast cancer
unfortunately the epidemiologic evidence
has been largely inconclusive
um mostly showing null associations or
an inverse Association but only within
specific subgroups
these are data from a meta-analysis and
really if you focus on the right hand
panel these are the nested case control
studies so those are studies in which
the blood was sampled prior to any
disease and it really shows very modest
uh inverse association with breast
cancer
so we were really interested in trying
to better understand the impact of
vitamin D on uh breast cancer and breast
health and we leverage data from the
vital trial and this is a randomized
control trial of high-dose vitamin D
it's a two by two factorial design which
means that women were meant this was a
study of men and women were randomized
to vitamin D and omega-3 fatty acids or
Placebo for either one of those and the
parent study was really focused on
understanding the impact of high-dose
vitamin D and omega-3 on cancer and
heart disease
these were the main findings from the
study they did not see an association
with breast cancer there was some
suggestive evidence that perhaps perhaps
death from cancer and this is death from
all cancers uh maybe maybe inversely
Associated
um with randomization to vitamin D
so our goal really our rationale was
that we felt the data with respect to
breast cancer risk was null or
inconclusive there is some suggested
evidence that vitamin D may be
associated with improved breast cancer
survival and it's really important to
note that vital was not powered to
specifically examine breast cancer risk
and really given the long latency for
breast cancer which is sort of on the
order of 15 to 20 years unlikely that we
would see an impact on breast cancer
during the five years of active
treatment
our objective was really to see if we
could see an impact of high-dose vitamin
D on mammographic density and texture
features as well as an impact on gene
expression patterns in breast tissue
so we conducted a ancillary study to
this vital trial and we connect
collected mammograms prior to
randomization as well as post
randomization one year after
randomization three years after
randomization in four years after
randomization and we were able to
collect mammograms on over 3 000 women
with on average more than four mammogram
time points per individual women
these are the main results of that study
and just to orient you we are looking at
the percent change in the percent
mammographic density the yellow bubbles
are those that were women that were
randomized to vitamin D and the blue
bubbles are women that were randomized
to Placebo and what you can see is we
actually don't really see much of an
impact on
um you see that everyone is reducing and
this is expected as women age their
percent mammographic density does
decrease but we don't really see a
difference between those randomized to
vitamin D and those randomized to
placebo
what is interesting is that we do see a
difference in this V texture measure and
this V texture measure may be a little
bit more sensitive of a measure relative
to percent mammographic density and so
you can see that the line is a little
bit steeper for vitamin D the yellow
bars have a steeper decline than what
you see
um with the blue with the blue bubbles
um suggesting that that vitamin D
supplementation may have a stronger
impact in reducing this V measure which
is associated with breast cancer
um more so than in the women on placebo
the other thing that we are able to do
is that we collected from the women in
this vital trial
um because we followed them up and we
asked them if they had been diagnosed
with a benign breast disease or breast
cancer we collected those archival
tissues specimens and we conducted gene
expression profiling using rna-seq
um Dr Chung Pang conducted Gene set
enrichment analysis with the cancer
Hallmark genes the other thing that she
did was she developed a vitamin D score
so looking at the people that were
randomized to vitamin D versus not
vitamin D created a score and then we
tested that in an external population to
be able to look at the impact on breast
cancer survival
and what we found was a number the red
dotted line is signifies FDR's
significance and what we found was a
number of
um Gene sets that were down regulated in
the women that were randomized to
high-dose vitamin D so we saw a
significant down regulation of specific
Pathways including proliferative
Pathways cell cycle related Pathways
inflammation and these all of these
models were adjusted for age and er
status as well as stage
so in that second analysis that I
mentioned Chung created a vitamin D
score which tried to create a genetic
gene expression signature
um based on the women that were
randomized to high-dose vitamin D
relative to to not
and what we found on the left-hand panel
is this Gene score we divided it up into
tertiles and looked to see how the gene
expression score was related to breast
cancer recurrence and we found that
those that had a high vitamin D score
had a reduced risk of developing uh
recurrence and you can see on the right
hand panel a very similar analysis but
using metabrick
and it's very consistent with respect to
both studies finding an inverse
association with this high vitamin D
score and a very similar magnitude
so to conclude the vitamin D portion
um we found that high dose vitamin D was
not associated with significant declines
in percent mammographic density however
we did find a suggestive and supportive
evidence that high-dose vitamin D may
have a stronger impact on the compared
with Placebo and this may be due to the
fact that they may be a slightly more
sensitive uh measure of what is
happening in the breast
we also find evidence that high-dose
vitamin D supplementation influence
breast tumor gene expression profiles
and creating this vitamin D signature
was associated with improved survival in
independent study populations
so I think we're still somewhere between
one and two I think we've you know
understand more of the science than we
ever have and I do think we are getting
uh really close into identifying
high-risk populations to the point where
we could make some actionable changes
unfortunately I think we're still uh you
know I think 0.3 and 0.4 are areas which
a lot of research is being done and
really where we need to focus our next
efforts
so just to conclude everything that
we've discussed today there is strong
and robust evidence not just from the
work I've presented but from other work
that early life adiposity is inversely
associated with breast cancer evidence
that novel Imaging features uh can
improve breast cancer risk prediction
there is suggested evidence that
high-dose vitamin D supplementation May
improve breast cancer outcomes and
really I think you know the next steps
are for future work to really better
identify these modifiable factors so
that we can come up with actionable
recommendations for the prevention and
improved survival of women from breast
cancer
with that I would like to acknowledge
um so many people go into doing this
kind of research I have a fantastic set
of collaborators listed here and I think
very importantly the participants that
participate in breast cancer research
and all kinds of epidemiologic research
specifically here the nurses health
study participants in the vital study
participants who have contributed their
time their effort their samples uh
really none of this research would be
doable without their efforts
and with that I thank you and if anyone
has any questions please do reach out
I've left my email here and I'm happy to
um talk with anyone who's interested
thank you again for your attention